if you ever take a trip across the pond
to some of the more rural parts of the
british isles you might just hear some
tales of a dark shadowy shame a creature
stalking through the night an omen of
death it's an entity that has been known
by many names
including the grim or black shuck most
folks will tell you the same that this
nightmare takes on the form of a huge
black dog but is also known to be able
to change its shape often appearing at
nighttime the apparition is said to be
demonic in nature commonly associated
with the devil himself believed by some
to be a hellhound like garmer and
cerberus guardians of the underworld in
norse and greek mythology the dog is far
larger than your average pet with big
glowing eyes it is also known to stock
crossroads ancient pathways and places
where executions took place those who
catch sight of black shuck are often
befallen with bad luck and for some it
can even mean that death will soon be
upon them of course this is nothing more
than a bit of local folklore spooky
tales designed to drum up tourism but is
the black shark really just a legend or
is there something more to the tale
after all it's not as if a dog like that
could really exist could it enter
scp-023
otherwise known as yes you guessed it
the black shock much like the creatures
from the stories
scp-023 is an entity possessing a canine
form far larger than most domesticated
dogs
scp-023 is described as being shaggy in
appearance with black fur and glowing
orange red eyes as well as prominent
fangs through testing the scp foundation
has determined a number of the dog's
anomalous abilities first and foremost
legends have described the black shuck
as an apparition or spirit and much in
the same vein
scp-023 is able to pass right through
solid matter the creature can pass
through walls seemingly at will but does
also seem to have a physical form at
least when it is kept in containment to
prevent a breach the foundation keeps
scp-023 in a walled off intersection of
two corridors sporting fake doors at
three of its four ends with only one
real entrance why does the dog's
containment unit require such a specific
layout simple it has to resemble a
crossroad even if this is merely a
superficial resemblance remember that
the black chuck of legend often appeared
at crossroads a sign that would warn
those traveling of their impending doom
as long as scp-023 remains contained in
the cell resembling crossroads it cannot
pass through walls should the black
shuck ever escape this enclosure however
then it will use its anomalous abilities
to incinerate anything in its path the
dog can burn through walls no matter how
dense and will travel from location to
location by this method also in keeping
with a shock of folklore looking into
the eyes of scp-023 can hold potentially
devastating outcomes should any person
make direct eye contact with the dog
then death will be upon them within the
span of the next full year either the
person who looked at the black shuck in
the eye or a close member of their
family will die
just like a number of the legends state
the foundation has no concrete idea how
the shuck chooses its victims with no
patterns or obvious preferences only
that they will die a year after eye
contact researchers aren't even sure if
scp-023 selects its victims from the
moment eye contact is made or if this
choice is made during the year that
follows or even if it is a conscious
choice at all all that is known for
certain is that if you were to look into
the beast's glowing eyes there would be
no way for you to tell if you or a
relative would suffer the consequences
only when in the past the scp foundation
attempted to eliminate an individual
that looked into
scp-023's eyes along with their whole
family before the year was up trying to
take any potential victims away from the
black shuck before they could be hunted
down by the anomalous canine much like
the way the creature passes through
walls by incinerating solid matter the
way
scp-023 dispatches its chosen victims
seem to almost be linked to the use of
heat the foundation has conducted a
number of autopsies on those killed by
scp-023
and their findings have always yielded
the same result anyone killed by the
black shuck will not exhibit any signs
of external damage no burn marks on
their skin or any kind of contusions
however on closer inspection these
bodies appear to have been filled in
their insides replaced with highly
compacted ash all their organs and
internal bodily systems appear to be
incinerated by the black shuck but
somehow this occurs so rapidly that
there is no notable damage caused to the
outside of their bodies to prevent
scp-023 claiming any further victims the
foundation has another measure in place
the black chuck has been fitted with two
spheres made of hard rubber these are
inserted into the creature's sunken in
eye sockets blocking anyone from
accidentally making eye contact with it
however over time thanks to the heating
effect of the shook state these inserts
will begin to degrade when security
cameras detect that the glow of
scp-023's eyes have returned to a
dangerous level foundation personnel
will have to replace the rubber spheres
to once again block the creature's
vision however this can only be done
after sunset and any personnel tasked
with replacing the inserts are cautioned
not to look the dog in the eyes during
the process unless they want to become
the black shuck's next victim the scp
foundation first came into contact with
scp-023 when they received information
about an attack that had taken place at
a church while the location of this
incident is unknown if the legends are
to be believed the church may have been
located in the moors of a rural region
of the british isles while the church
was in the middle of a service the black
chuck entered and killed a number of
civilians in attendance presumably the
members of this congregation had all at
some point seen the large black dog out
in the moors or one of their relatives
had the foundation stepped in and
managed to capture the black shuck
giving amnestics to the survivors that
had witnessed the attack the damage done
by scp-023 and the deaths it caused were
covered up as attempted arson however
the foundation's trouble with scp-023
was far from over after the black shucks
capture at the church the dog was able
to breach containment on multiple
occasions at first it had been placed in
a standard containment chamber but it
was quickly able to incinerate through
the concrete walls of the cell
foundation personnel later discovered
that the dog had settled in in an
intersection between two corridors and
realized that it had resembled a
crossroad these exact corridors became
the basis for
scp-023's new containment chamber and
the assistant researcher originally
assigned to the dog was reprimanded for
negligence during this and other escape
attempts
scp-023 caused the deaths of a high
number of foundation personnel as a
direct result researchers assigned to it
requested that the black shuck be
reclassified as a ketter class anomaly
they also noted that scp-023 shared
certain traits with scp-1111-1
one of the two entities that form
scp-1111
scp-1111-1 also referred to as the white
dog possesses an almost ghostly
translucent canine form and abilities
that focus on geographic space in the
white dogs case it will attack anyone it
detects approaching scp-1111-2
the body of an unidentified man hanging
from a news
researchers working for the foundation
believe that scp-023 and
scp-1111-1 might be instances of the
same phenomenon but have been unable to
capture the white dog in order to verify
this given the number of deaths the
black chuck had caused research
personnel attempted to reduce the danger
that they faced when interacting with
the dog they helped to remove the
beast's eyes and teeth thus making it
safer however it was during an attempt
to do so that scp-023 once again managed
to breach containment at first
everything seemed to be going according
to plan but when researchers removed
scp-023's eyes the black chuck vanished
completely from its containment area scp
security staff scoured the area for it
eventually tracking the dog down to a
long stretch of interstate it is still
unknown exactly how many civilians may
have seen the black shuck as they drove
past it but so far nine deaths are
thought to have stemmed from this
incident the ghostly dog was recaptured
and d-class personnel removed its fangs
after analyzing the times of incidents
researchers realized that scp-023 had
only been able to escape while the sun
was up leading to new containment
procedures mandating that no staff
member was to interact with the shuck
until after sunset the interstate fiasco
led to the doctor assigned to watch over
scp-023 being suspended and facing a
disciplinary review from his foundation
superiors the blame for the breach and
security that caused the incident was
placed at his feet and a new doctor was
placed in charge of observing the black
shock unfortunately for this new
researcher the incidents involving
scp-023
did not stop there the newly appointed
doctor attempted to give the dog a pair
of glass eyes to replace the ones that
had been removed before the previous
containment breach perhaps they thought
it was a gesture of kindness a
compassionate act or maybe they just
thought it would look cool for a dog to
have glass eyes no matter the reason it
seemed they had forgotten for a moment
that this huge shadow creature was an
ancient evil entity and not a dog at all
when the doctor gave the new glass eyes
to scp-023
they immediately took on the exact same
properties as its old ones they began
glowing molten glass leaking from the
dog's sockets and appeared on all
reflective surfaces throughout the site
the shuck was being held at everything
from mirrors and windows to lenses and
glasses computer monitors anything and
everything glass the foundation suffered
an enormous number of deaths that day
even staff sitting in the cafeteria
would have seen a version of those
orange glowing eyes staring at them from
the bottom of their bulls marking them
for a fiery death the facility was
quickly evacuated but the damage had
already been done anyone that had seen a
reflection of the black shuck's eyes
would be dead within a year devastated
the new doctor in charge of overseeing
scp-023
blamed themselves for dooming their
research team as well as the rest of the
foundation staff in the facility when
the sun came up over the horizon a
number of d-class personnel were sent
into
scp-023's enclosure only to find that
the dog had once again vanished the only
trace it had left behind was a puddle of
molten glass burning part of the floor a
year later any and all personnel that
had gazed into the black chuck's eyes
were dead and the remains were buried in
a mass unmarked grave near the
containment facility despite the doctor
vowing to recapture and contain
scp-023 it remains unclear if they were
ever actually successful there is a
chance that the black chuck has been
gradually making its way back home to
the moors of the british isles if so we
advise you not to travel after sundown
unless you absolutely have to and if you
find yourself at a crossroad then pray
you don't catch sight of a hulking
demonic hound staring out at you with
eyes that burn through the dark if you
do well
we hope you enjoy your year now go check
out
scp-1913 deadly monster squad the furies
and
scp-1337 the hitchhiker for more freaky
creatures from the scp foundation